elles ont continué à 7,8 week-end on va
parler exposition va parler art avec
vous marie-pierre dunod bonjour vous
êtes artiste plasticienne et vous êtes
aussi un intervenant tant qu'on a
rappelé à ce ticket en art thérapie
depuis neuf ans il ya une exposition du
collectif d'une aux harkis est proposée
samedi et dimanche dans un lieu je
qualifierais de très bucolique les
grosses de port royal à magny les
hameaux alors quel est le but de cette
exposition
alors c'est une exposition qui regroupe
les différents ateliers peinture et
sculpture qui ont travaillé toute
l'année
voilà et donc il y aura 42 exposants
peintres et sculpteurs amateurs
voilà donné une performance il ya une
performance à 18h30 une performance
artistique oui c'est moi il va fondre
ces artistes à l'heure en gros on
réalise en deux ans on a vingt minutes
on l'a préparé bien sûr mais en vingt
minutes on doit donner quelque chose
d'intéressant à voir qui se construit au
fur et à mesure de ce petit temps en 20
minutes c'est sa performance elle sera
sur l'activité sculpture ou peintes
sculpture c'est de la sculpture donc
voilà c'est métallique je peux dire ça
ça représente un peu une idée de la mode
voilà et donc c'est un personnage est
intégralement par qui alors par patrick
deguines qui s'éteint
qui est une personne qui vient sculpté
avec moi depuis n'ont donc ça d'autres
calliopée à ménil yann moix samedi à 18
ans tendre pour découvrir cette cette
performance ça doit être assez
impressionnant de faire des performances
comme ça devant un public tout le monde
regarde oui voilà on l'a pris tard mais
c'est aussi c'est aussi l'art
contemporain c'est s'inscrire dans les
ateliers aussi dans des seules choses
novatrices voilà on apprend les
techniques de sculpture mais à partir de
là qu'est ce qu'on en fait c'est ce qui
est intéressant de développer sa propre
créativité
vous n'êtes pas il me semble que tu as
les opposants vivement et vers quel
public vous êtes amené à travailler
alors moi je travaille avec des publics
différents je travaille avec
l'association des paralysés de france
qui d'ailleurs demain soir après notre à
nice âge organise un repas champêtre
suivi du d'une un film
donc avec les stations cela soit
paralysée le france avec le centre
calliopée le cmp de magny les hameaux
avec avec deux centres d'adultes
handicapés mentaux mais aussi dans des
associations de publique disons
ordinaire on peut dire et moi ce que
j'essaie de faire dans les stages que je
relise des buteurs c'est plutôt là vous
êtes sort à un public plutôt tourné vers
le handicap
oui oui mais sa simple dans sa valise
alala des passes pour moi la question du
handicap et donc l'important c'est de de
développer sa propre créativité et dans
son année moyens c'est aller vers
l'extérieur et c'est intéressant de
d'organiser des stages très ouvert voilà
et donc c'est ce que c'est ce que je
fais depuis un an et demi maintenant à
l'abbaye de port royal puisque bon voilà
nous consommateurs nous a proposé 200
votre association qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle la rente est l'association
l'art en tête qui est kate à magny les
hameaux
voilà et donc nous organisons jeanine
ces stages de sculpture
alors ça se passe dans l'ombre et pour
tout public c'est à dire que public
adulte ou adolescents mais disons pas
trop bas trop jeune on ne voit là et
donc nous scrutons à le béton cellulaire
ensuite quand on est un petit peu
aguerris on travaille une pierre tendre
jusqu'à des pierres plus dur toute la
semaine mais comment ça se passe en fait
franchir ce mélange ne mouillent pas
très très heureux et comment ça se passe
cette mixité entre personnes dites
ordinaires le mot n'est pas bon quand il
valait rien trouvé d'autre mais d'ici là
et puis les personnes qui pourraient
avoir des handicaps dans un handicap
moteur ou psychique même plus oui oui
tout à fait il ya et ça se passe très
très bien il ya aucun souci puisque là
on est dans dans une pratique
bon de toute façon il ya une aide d'au
moins huit personnes dans le stage on ne
l'est pas forcément prêt de toutes les
personnes en même temps
il ya naturellement une aide qui se fait
et un échange un échange de vécu qui
aide aussi à la créativité
on peut dire voilà qu'un vrai vin
échanges en fait un vrai changement là
d'accord quelqu'un est le fer de lance
de votre action alors c'est certain ce
qu'on appelle le un peu maintenant
l'inclusion c'est à dire ne pas rester
dans les institutions être à l'extérieur
et
voilà et se dépasser voilà et dépasser
ses difficultés sachant que les autres
noms aussi même si c'est un public
ordinaire donc voila se dire qu'on n'est
pas tout seul dans ce qu'on vit et voilà
donc vous aviez vous êtes artiste pas si
saine qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
de vous tourner vers l'art thérapie ce
qu'on appelle l'art thérapie qui est
faite elle détonateur ou par nécessité
pour vous ilan et c'est à dire que j'ai
toujours travaillé dans le dans le
social donc je travaille dans
l'insertion et puis naturellement ggg
d'aidé éducateur à monter des ateliers
de poterie de modelage de structurer et
j'ai et j'ai vu que il y avait vraiment
bon voilà un travail à faire dans ce
domaine là et donc c'est pour ça que je
me suis lancé mais pas dans les
institutions vers l'extérieur comment on
travaille c'est public si différents je
présume une attention très particulière
louis les sur certaines pathologies
une façon de travailler mais c'est
également vous travaillez la même
manière non non non il ya une attente il
ya il ya un travail individuel qui suit
parce qu'on est tous ne partent pas du
même point donc il ya des personnes qui
n'ont qu'une main pour travailler et
pourtant à la fin elles peuvent
travailler sur une pierre dure faire un
bas relief au départ et à prévenir et je
crois que justement le travail d'art
thérapie ce qu on oublie ce qui nous
arrive être ancré dans sa difficulté on
la dépasse mais petit à petit et le
résultat alors est ce que il ya des sas
ratio gàv viennent là là c'est le
résultat est effectivement il me voir
concrètement ce week-end au grand jour
en moyenne mais bien suivi des élèves
dynamique sur plusieurs années plusieurs
années et vous voyez une amélioration
oui la dévolution leroyer fortement
bien sûr mais a su bien sûr d'un certain
dans un certain lieu les gens que l'on
accueille ont eu des difficultés
psychiques bon suite à des deuils enfin
voilà et là la question artistes permet
de dépasser ces difficultés là d'aller
vers autre chose voilà ce se découvrir
autrement
donc vous savez forcément des bons
souvenirs oui d'ailleurs des belles
histoires non de belles histoires
tout à fait merci à mr regarder d'autres
avenues sont qu'à toute cette suite ce
week-end donc je rappelle que
l'exposition à magny les hameaux
c'est à l'heure initiale kent donc déjà
mais voilà il y avait deux heures à 18
heures et puis ils sont conviés dimanche
à l'hôtel
18h40 la fois l'avancé des personnes
veulent venir en stage il ya des stages
donc en juillet et fin août et même
stage à en bourgogne du 20 au 27 juillet
voilà ils peuvent nous contacter soit
lié à la fois stage étage alors voilà et
puis j'ai lu resculpter gemalto pour
ceux qui peuvent pas ne peuvent pas
venir voir l'expression ce week-end le
centre calliopée à magny les hameaux
accueille aussi l'exposition du 17 juin
au 30 août voilà ripolin donc c'est là
une prolongation de des travaux de vos
élèves merci beaucoup d'être calé sur le
plateau 17,8 week-end merci